here's a guy who was a really good
Georgia offensive lemon blocking for
Jake from he's Andrew Thomas Andrew how
are you buddy I'm doing good excited to
be here what what do you what do you
think of all this combined experience so
far you've been in town a couple of days
to take it in
I was pretty crazy I'm doing my best
trying to take it all in a lot coming at
you but I'm excited for it you got Jake
froms trying to rise up the draft board
be his hype man tell tell me why he's
the man and why he should be taken among
the top quarterbacks he's a leader soon
as he comes into the room he's gonna fit
the team he could make all the throws
and I think the best part of the game is
just how smart he is like he makes all
the checks for us if he sees pressure
coming he'll change it so if you bring
him on your team I feel like he'll you
know make an immediate impact my office
give me your best story of a moment
where he did something said something
got you guys pointed in the right
direction to to perform the way you
needed to in a big spot we were playing
in the Rose Bowl my freshman year and we
had a five man protection pass play call
and the way they outlined Jake didn't
like it so he switched it to a inside
zone play where Sonny went was in the
backfield and it hit four it says now in
the Rose Bowl and moments like that they
have an impact right that's when you
believe in a guy and you think well
right we're gonna listen to this guy
going forward definitely yeah so tell me
a little bit more about yourself Andrew
Thomas and specifically I'm fasting with
a big guy like you and go we talked to a
couple other guys you know six five when
when did you get that big spurt well how
old were you when you went from being
you know a little kid to all of a sudden
well this guy's on his way to possibly
play an either in the NBA the NFL so I
was about 511 and the eighth grade I was
looking my mom and I remember and then
at the end of my freshman year I hit a
huge Pro sport I was like 250 at the
time I gained like 50 pounds and like
three four inches see I was 511 in the
eighth row anymore yeah I have not grown
at all since I was 14 years old just oh
you got lucky and you added six more
inches and here you are on your way how
hard is it for you to keep your weight
on um it's not that hard actually during
this process of trying to I've been
actually you know coming down I play a
little heavier this year so I've been
okay what's your ideal number around
3:15 3:20 who are you a fan I've grown
up player player probably michael vick
yo grew up in Georgia yes sir
yeah the the guys in the NFL now when
you're out there for the first time on
the field ready to play who's gonna be
that guy that makes you say oh my god I
can't believe I'm out here with him
probably be Tom Brady if I played
against him that would be crazy
who was the guy that gave you the
hardest time in college the hardest guy
for you to block I would say my freshman
year it was my first road game at the
block Jeff Hager from Barber yeah why
was it so tough for you it was just my
first road game I remember not being
that you know here to plays here to snap
counts things like that he was a great
pass rusher but we played him again an
SEC Championship and I fared pretty well
against what's what's allowed to stadium
you experienced in college either Auburn
or Tennessee and what what you know help
people understand because they hear it
all the time oh it's so hot but but what
makes it so difficult for you when
you're in a place like that and it's
loud and they're yelling curse words at
you you're trying to focus on your job
what makes it difficult for you
specifically it makes it very difficult
as office a lot because you know we have
to communicate all of us have to be on
the same page and so when Jake's trying
to give us a plate and we can't hear it
makes it you know pretty difficult
especially with a stem or they show
pressure late it's hard to adjust to it
really quickly what kinds of things did
you guys do at Georgia to practice for
those situations I will go in the indoor
and close smart will turn on the crowd
noise the highest didn't go be pretty
loud and we'll practice you know
different peers
you know what the crowd noise real out
does the highest it can go still make it
as loud as what it's like when you're in
that stadium so when we have it on it's
usually against like you know the scout
team so it's not it's as loud but it's
not as intense but you know we go to
Auburn or you go to Tennessee you plan
against you know their starters is loud
and the guys are you know very good you
get an advantage playing in an SEC
environment like that it's not as big of
a jump when you go to the NFL and I'm
sure you've talked to former teammates
and guys that have played in the SEC and
it's got to give you more confidence
going to the NFL that you're not making
that huge leap if you had been at the
smaller school and a smaller conference
would not nearly as many people in the
stadium
yeah it definitely does um planning an
SEC every week it's a challenge
obviously is not the NFL but it's a good
you know
upon getting up to the next level who's
the guy that you're looking forward to
blocking so blocking I probably say
probably like Lauren Miller or Khalil
Matt you know they're the top of the
game on an NFL they've been the best
last couple of years so I feel like you
know they'll be pretty good challenge
for me you know there's been more of an
emphasis recently put on run blocking
especially the way the 49ers do it and
they make they turn it into an art firm
almost for you what do you prefer pass
blocking or run blocking I probably say
run blocking at Georgia that was the
main thing we did run the ball at the
point of a second you know make pass
plays off of that that's when you get to
go tack someone drop it on the ground
right pass blocking they're coming at
you run blocking you're going at them
right all right well you're going at the
NFL buddy and we appreciate some of your
time we wish you all the best Andrew
Thomas Georgia offensive linemen will be
back with Colts head coach Frank Reich
here in Indianapolis he didn't have to
drive price leppe at home last night
I'll talk to Frank right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports